et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexandre orlov ancien ambassadeur de
russie en france bonsoir vous publiez
vos mémoires un ambassadeur russe à
paris aux éditions fayard à vos côtés
gérard longuet ancien ministre de la
défense bonsoir bonsoir merci à tous les
deux d'avoir accepté notre invitation en
direct sur rt france alors on le disait
dans le sillage de l'attentât de
conflans sainte honorine le président
emmanuel macron a donc demandé à
vladimir poutine un renforcement de la
coopération antiterroriste et c'est ici
un un terrain comme à intensifier
alexandre orlov
oui bien sûr je crois que c'est un des
sujets importants dans nos relations
d'ailleurs je dois dire que les contacts
entre les services sont mus culture jour
lieu mais je crois que après cet
assassinat barbare qui s'est passé il
fallait bien se voir au niveau du
ministre de l'intérieur pour faire un
peu le point one est et à mon avis
mettre un peu de l'ordre dans la
question du don de 2000 grâce ion des
tricheurs en france puisque je me
souviens que les autorités françaises à
l'époque accordé très facilement l'asile
politique à chichen dès qu'ils disaient
que je suis tchétchène était le bienvenu
en france on faisait aucune enquête pour
se voir rien sur son passé là je crois
qu'on pourrait faire quand même
davantage faire attention mais sinon là
la diaspora tchétchène en france est une
déesse paranormal il ya beaucoup
d'autres diaspora qui survivent en
france il faut pas penser que tous les
chiens sont des terroristes mais
néanmois une coordination accrue entre
le service entre le ministère de
l'intérieur est bienvenu alors gérard
longuet les autorités françaises dont
vous avez fait partie au plus haut
niveau
est ce qu on a été laxiste ou au sujet
justement de cette question de l'accueil
des réfugiés tchétchènes en france en
fait nous avons une autorité
administrative qui est bien informé et
gour heureuse et qui en ce qui concerne
l'accueil des réfugiés politiques et
finalement assez exigeante et à côté de
cela nous avons c'est une tradition une
autorité judiciaire qui est un recours
contre les décisions administratives qui
est bienveillance je vais pas prendre un
autre terme bienveillante et qui
considère que chacun a droit voire une
nouvelle chance qui fait que dans deux
attentats récents celui qui a coûté la
mort se mêlent fatigue comme celui qui
est commis devant les anciens locaux de
charlie nous avions des des réfugiés
politiques pour lesquels là c'est la
justice qui leur a permis de rester dans
le cas de l'assassin de du porteur
force est de reconnaître qu'il était en
france depuis douze ans il était rentré
enfants il devait avoir entre 6 et 8 ans
et par contre étant évidemment et l'a
suivi et accompagné ses parents il
n'était pas lui même concerné par une
enquête et disons que d'une façon
générale l'opinion française et à titre
personnel je considère que nous sommes
bien outillé entre les mais nous avons
un droit qui est très bienveillant et
très protecteur peut être excessivement
bien
ayant excessivement protecteur lorsqu'il
y a un contentieux
alors on se souvient au lendemain des
attentats du bataclan la france et la
russie avaient décidé de coopérer
militairement pour frapper notamment des
ch en syrie racontez-nous alexandre
orlov
comment cette relation s'est elle passée
ce que tu veux ans après les attentats
je crois que j'ai fait en novembre 2015
au bataclan
françois hollande a déclaré une guerre
aux terroristes qui sont venus de la
syrie il est allé en visite à moscou je
les accompagne j'étais présent aux
entretiens entre françois hollande
les lumières poutine et françois
hollande a dit qu'elle va est la france
va participer ensemble avec la russie à
ce que à ce combat contre les
terroristes
en syrie la france a dépêché le porte
avions charles de gaulle vers les côtes
de la syrie et les lumières poutine a
donné l'ordre aux militaires russes de
considérer les militaires français comme
les alliés mais moi je crois que c'est
également très important de notre
histoire et sans puisque c'est pour la
première fois depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale que les français étaient
considérés comme nos alliés il ya eu
même des bombes qui ont été lâchés sur
les terroristes en syrie sur l'étude on
écrivait pour venger par il y avait un
grand sentiment de solidarité de
d'alliance avec la france dans ce combat
contre les terroristes qui avaient leurs
malles des ch en syrie et puis alors la
france
à faire appeler son porte-avions des
codes de la série à toulon sans prévenir
la russie et ses voeux du maire peut-il
lui même lors d'une conférence de presse
je me suis un caddie que un jour j'ai
appris que nos alliés nous nous ont
quittés en syrie alors c'est comme ça
que les choses se sont passées gérard
longuet ce que vous venez d'entendre ce
que c'est une faute diplomatique selon
vous est ce que la france a été
embarrassé par la suite avait avec cette
ce comportement est de reconnaître que
notre politique en syrie n'a pas été
d'une très grande clarté ce depuis le
début des du printemps arabe 2008 nous
avons joué sur différents lots et je
pense que nous n'avons pas trouvé le bon
il ya eu une condamnation systématique
du pouvoir de bagdad de damas qui a
évidemment durci position de damas avait
et qui a interrompu les relations que
nous avions entre avis légende de syrie
apportant des informations qui étaient
extrêmement utile au gouvernement de
damas excellente et le service français
nous avons cru trouver des
interlocuteurs modéré évidemment dans un
pays en guerre civile
à peu près impossible paix et modéré
s'il existe 16 ou s'en vont la syrie
était un champ d'affrontement ex
d'affrontements de survie les
belligérants n'était pas dans un débat
d'idées tu es moche comme perspective
pour les uns et pour les autres et
chaque communauté est certes le pouvoir
de damas ils étaient des moyens la 3 de
la guerre condamne j'étais le dos au mur
c'est un gouvernement des minorités
c'est peut-être un gouvernement
minoritaire
comment des minorités mais ce sont des
minorités qui n'entendent par être
éradiquée et donc la situation syrienne
était telle que nous n'avons jamais su
en est les gouvernements de françois
hollande n'ont pas su trouver un vrai
partenaire est d'ailleurs dans une ère
de ce type
pouvons-nous de l'extérieur choisir le
bon partenaire et séparer le bon grain
de l'ivraie
aucun ne mérite et là en quelque sorte
une bénédiction française a réussi a
fait un choix différent qui était le
choix du gouvernement en place
un choix qui a le mérite de la
simplicité de la clarté
il ya un gouvernement en place est ce
qu'il est on ne porte pas de jugement
sur sa politique simplement retenu par
les autres états et dès lors qu'il n'est
en place
or de ne pas le déstabiliser choix à n'a
jamais été au fond mon condamné en
france
le choix de la russie d'intervenir
auprès de damas n'a jamais été soutenue
n'a jamais été condamné j'avais été
condamné parce qu'on savait
qu'intervenant ainsi les russes
contribuer à à faire en sorte que des
shs détruits et détruit en particulier
aussi parler fort de damas et en même
temps ne pouvait pas approuver parce que
le sentiment que que damas avait sa part
de responsabilité dans la guerre civile
et est évidente billy el-assad est quand
même une famille qui a régné par force
pendant près de quarante ou cinquante
donc voilà nous avons en france je dois
reconnaître en syrie nous n'avons jamais
su trouver le message clair nous avons
été à la recherche d'alliés qui n'ont
jamais existé
alexandre orlov cette lutte
conjointe de l'art issus de la russie et
de la france aujourd'hui
comment est ce qu elle peut se
concrétiser ça passe par où passe cette
lutte de entre la russie et la france
contre le terrorisme contre le crime
organisé va s'organiser avant tout je
crois au tour de l' échange
d'informations il faudrait que le dieu
ministère de l'intérieur ont une
information régulière sur les cas
suspects sur pourra faire les déments
sur telle ou telle ressortissants qui se
trouvent actuellement sur le seul choix
de la france la russie pour faire une
enquête va qu'elles sont passées à quel
point elle peut être dangereux pour tel
ou tel pays je crois que ça d'autre part
il ya eu aussi des personnes qui sont en
situation irrégulière
là il faut quand même faire une
distinction entre des réfugiés
politiques des hanches statut qui est
obstat eu officiele se trouve en france
comme réfugié politique c'est la france
qui porte un tiers responsabilité de ces
gens là et c'est le cas de ce tchétchène
qui a assassiné le pauvre processeurs a
confiance à tamarin mais il ya aussi des
gens qui se trouvent en situation
irrégulière ou bien il ya aussi des
réfugiés politiques qui ont passé
terroriste et des fois je me souviens
quand j'étais ambassadeur le service
passer l'information à des services
compétents en france est un des rares
que nous voulons que cette personne soit
extradé pour être jugé pour les crimes
qu'il a commis en russie pendant la
guerre en tchétchénie au pendant son
séjour sur notre territoire
d'ailleurs je me sais bien que souvent
les services compétents français était
tout à fait d'accord puisqu'ils partager
ce journaliste qui était fait sur les
donner quand même objectif mais
malheureusement ce sont des autres
instances de l'état français qui
interdisez l'expulsion de ces
terroristes de la france en russie
alors j'espère que avec je trouvais les
rencontres on pourra enfin régler ce
contentieux
gérard longuet vous vous partagez les
mots qu'on entend qu'on a entendu un
stand avec son orlov sur le cam a subi
grandes écoles avec un bémol
l'ambassadeur orlov connaît
admirablement d'autres pays où il est
ailleurs s'amenant apprécié il y a les
gens qui ont la responsabilité d'ordre
public ce sont en effet les
collaborateurs de l'état il sert de
l'intérieur parfois du mystère de la
défense et il est temps il en est ainsi
et c'est bon qu'il en soit ainsi
la justice en france la dgcc parfaite
indépendance je considère que le parquet
ouah mettre en oeuvre une politique
pénale décidées par le gouvernement
et c'est lui qui le met en oeuvre et la
justice qui rend le jugement cette
erreur d'appelants chez nous la justice
du siège des magistrats 6e avec le droit
et ne se sente d'heuliez 60 balayée par
les préoccupations immédiates du
gouvernement
si vous considérez mauvaise changer là
et nous nous la paix ont ils existent et
c'est parfois set ou deux opérations de
compassion qu'il est d'ailleurs à
propres problèmes du terrorisme ont
rencontrés dans d'autres formes de
délinquance heureusement moins graves
ce seuil à puce entre ceux qui ont la
responsabilité de l'ordre public il dit
juge endroit et cet écart est parfois
mal compris par l'opinion française est
mal compris en l'espèce par l'opinion
russe
je l'imaginais ce qui est nouveau c'est
que nous sommes dans une situation de
guerre est dans une situation de guerre
il y a des priorités la priorité c'est
l'ordre public au public non pas au
détriment des libertés
mais en appliquant le droit avec le
sens le plus exact de la préoccupation
d'ordre public
ce qui à certains moments étaient moins
importants aujourd'hui au nombre de
l'assassinât et d'attentats faire très
attention
alors on sort particulier où il suivit
de toute l'édition fiche alors on arrive
au terme de cette interview mais
alexandre orlov je le disais vous sortez
votre livre un ambassadeur en
ambassadeur russe à paris aux éditions
fayard ouvrage dans lequel vous raconter
pour 27 ans de poste à paris vous avez
commencé votre carrière sous l'ère
pompidou vous l'avez terminé sous la
présidence à des manuels macron quel
regard vous portez sur l'évolution de
notre pays
c'est un regard positif
bien sûr puisque je vais évoluer la
france avec le monde le monde a changé
le monde a évolué c'est pourquoi on peut
pas des gens comparer les situations que
j'ai connu quand je suis venu à à paris
à 71 sous georges pompidou et quand j'ai
quitté mon poste en 2010 est ce aux
nouvelles macro mais je dois dire que
pour nous pour les russes pour le port
et le président vladimir poutine
la france il y à 50 ans et aujourd'hui a
été et reste le partenaire principal en
europe et dans le monde
il y à une proximité exceptionnel
culturelle mettant seulement je croyais
aussi une grande proximité politique
bon il ya des problèmes qui nous
divisent sûrement aidera dans l'avenir
d'autres problèmes aussi mais les
diplomates sont faits pour ça pourra en
parler pour les chefs d'état les
ministres il faut tout simplement avoir
un dialogue plus actifs se voir plus
souvent se parler plus souvent murphy
très confiant dans l'avenir des
relations franco russes
un grand merci alexandre orlov d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien ambassadeur de russie
en france merci à vous gérard longuet
ancien ministre de la défense
art